ya casi terminado estas son las antiguas
insignias se escribe rpf por royal
barbados poli sports
pero desde el 1 de diciembre del año
pasado nos hemos convertido en una
república ahora somos el servicio de
policía de barbados
el inspector root ninis acaba de recibir
las nuevas carreteras de la policía de
barbados hoy los presenta su equipo una
estrella con el tridente de barbados en
lugar de la corona británica
así que dime lo que piensas si parece
muy creativo sobre todo el nuevo escudo
y así
me recuerda a mi infancia
representan a barbados todos los adornos
de la monarquía británica serán
eliminados de los uniformes de la
policía pero para el inspector rod ninis
el cambio es sobre todo simbólico que
hayamos cambiado de nombre no significa
que vayamos a olvidar nuestra rica
historia queremos conservarla y a todos
nos apasionan todos los policías siguen
muy apegados a ella desde el 30 de
noviembre isabel de inglaterra ya no es
reina de barbados esta antigua colonia
de las antillas británicas se ha
convertido en la república más joven del
mundo desde la independencia de barbados
en 1966 la cuestión republicana se ha
planteado muchas veces pero nunca se ha
resuelto al final todo lo que se
necesitaba era una chispa
así que aquí es donde estaba la estatua
del orden el señor
cientos de años
la estatua del almirante nelson figura
del imperio colonial británico se
encuentra desde hace tiempo en la plaza
de los héroes de la capital
era un lugar muy controvertido tras
estudiar historia en el extranjero álex
downs vuelve a trabajar en barbados en
2019 ya saben era la época del
movimiento blanc life
todo el mundo estaba interesado en las
injusticias raciales
sea un verdadero deseo de comprender
pese a la petición alrededor del 7 de
junio de 2000 creó un mensaje
change.org y lo publique
en todo el mundo se están retirando
estatuas a símbolos del colonialismo
álex down también decide actuar
me invitaron ese día así que aproveché
para bueno asegurarme de tener un
recuerdo realmente fue un momento
histórico el dramón años siempre nos
hablaban de esta estatua y nunca pensé
que realmente sucederle y que yo sería
quien la derribaran
un año después otro símbolo del pasado
colonial desapareció con la proclamación
de la republika de barbados tras este
cambio de régimen el primer ministro
anuncia elecciones anticipadas
en la sede del partido de mía mottley
los resultados llegan poco a poco
a última hora de la noche se contaron
todos los votos la población renovó
masivamente su apoyo a mía mottley al
igual que en 2018 su partido ganó todos
los escaños del parlamento
[Música]
la república parlamentaria más joven del
mundo ha reforzado su compromiso con los
más altos estándares de la democracia
la proclamación de la republika no
encontró ninguna oposición real pero
este cambio simbólico es solo un paso
hacia la construcción de una identidad
nacional barbados todavía lleva las
cicatrices de un pasado doloroso aquí en
el sur de la isla en esta antigua
plantación casi 600 esclavos fueron
enterrados en una fosa común
bendita sea esta mañana por lo que
debemos hacer y el conocimiento que
debemos impartir en este lugar el
historiador kevin farmer está
supervisando la construcción de un
monumento en memoria de los esclavos
murió el monumento conmemorativo se va a
construir allí mismo en esa colina vende
la fosa común
ahora que somos una república es muy
importante celebrar y conmemorar uno de
los pocos lugares que dan testimonio del
pasado
no solo soy consciente de mi pasado
quiero inspirarme en él
quiero entenderlo nuestra historia es
motivo de orgullo no hay que
avergonzarse de ella
a nosotros isabel segunda sigue
gobernando en ocho estados del caribe
para muchos de ellos la monarquía
desaparecerá en jamaica el 55% de la
población está ahora a favor de la
república